What's up YouTube and welcome back to
the channel. Today we have an issue with
the New Holland and the issue is water
in the hydraulic lines. So I'm going to
show you how to drain the reservoir and
to flush the lines without removing the
skid plate underneath and also show you
one of the main reasons for this
problem. So stay tuned and let's get it
started.
[Music]
So to confirm, we do have water in the
line. If you remove your
dipstick, you will notice that is white
and
milky. And you can see that it's
contaminated with water.
So, what we're going to do
is we're going to remove the dipstick
here and we're going to drain the tank
by siphoning out the oil from the tank.
So, first thing you want to do is get as
much of the contaminated oil out as
possible.
So, the first thing we're going to do is
remove the
dipstick and we're going to siphon
everything out through
here. Like I said, you can
see definitely
contaminated. So once you get your dipst
stick
removed, what you want to do is what I
use is a small
pump. Um you can get these sheet pretty
much anywhere and it hooks to your
battery.
connect
it. And we're going to put it into the
reservoir. And the other end we're going
to put into a bucket.
[Music]
[Applause]
Definitely. Go. We're going to pump this
out
until it stops. So, that'll be your
first step is to get everything pumped
out. So, one of the main reasons that
this particular brand gets water in the
reservoir is on the cap. If you
notice that inside, you'll notice that
there's a
filter
which if it's not in the right place, it
will let water seep through these holes
and enter
in. And the other reason is around here,
if you notice how this is designed, as
water comes in or it rains, it should
run off to the side here. But over time,
there's a gasket under here. And if that
gasket goes out, water accumulates here,
and it just drains down into the tank.
So, normally I keep this covered up, but
unfortunately I didn't get it covered up
and we had a lot of rain, so I knew that
was the problem. So, going to take this
off and check the gasket also and
possibly make another gasket and put
silicone in here. So, those are your two
reasons. one, double check to make sure
you have the filter in here, which is
that
inside. And then the other reason, check
to see if your gasket is worn out around
here. If it has, then just take this off
and put in a new gasket or put silicone
around it. And I'm going to show you how
to prevent that in the future.
[Music]
So, as you You can see this gasket
is in pretty bad
shape. So that could be the
culprit. And
underneath, which is here, it should
actually be another gasket here that
seals around here. And don't know if
it's just missing or in bad shape, but
you can see definitely
water. So that's our main
culprit. So another thing you can do is
you can pick up a pump like this, which
is
inexpensive, and that'll help speed up
everything while you're pumping with the
electric motor. But so far the reservoir
holds six and a half gallons and so far
we've pumped out about three and a half.
So that's the first section. We're going
to go empty that and start back pumping
again.
Then once you get everything emptied
out, we're going to refill the
reservoir and go out and run it. And
then we're going to open up the cylinder
line to see if we're getting clean fluid
up front. So, let's get it filled
up. Heat. Heat.
Once you refill it, cuz you're going to
have to flush the lines, you're going to
see how much is in here. So, we're going
to
take this line with your boom in the up
position.
So, we're just trying to get as much as
out of the lines as possible before we
refill it
again or reflush it. So, you loosen this
Heat up
here.
Heat.
Heat. Heat up
here.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
So once it's running clear with this
hydraulic fluid. We're going to check
the other lines, operate the machine,
and then come back and relead the lines
again.
Add to flush your auxiliary lines, which
we're going to do last because I hadn't
used it. So, it should
be good fluid in here. In order to keep
from breaking those lines, you basically
just take your plug. You got a plug here
and take the plug there. And then we'll
let it bleed out from here. But this
should have these lines should have good
fluid through them since I hadn't
operated those. But we got those bled.
And now let's go operate the machine and
come back and refill the reservoir and
bleed it
again. All right,
puppy
slow. All right,
stop.
Here
Yeah. All right.
[Music]
So, we got the system bled out and all
the water out the line. We're going to
bleed it one more time and then we'll
come back and bleed with the auxiliary
lines. But what I did is for the purpose
of the video, I just showed you what
comes out of the line so that you can
see the milky um oil that comes out. But
what I did is actually took a line and
connected it to the plug and then just
ran the other
end of the line into a bucket and just
pumped it out that way. Um, like I said,
for the purpose of the video, just
wanted to show you what comes out of the
line as you ble each line and then just
connect the line to it and just continue
to bleed it until you empty your bucket
and then you get clear fluid running out
into the bucket. But like I said, we'll
bleed the system one more time and then
we'll come back and bleed the hydraulic
lines just to make sure everything is
good.
So, the process is to make sure you keep
enough
oil in the system so when you're
bleeding it, you don't affect your pump.
So, I have
the fluid pumping into the system. And
once it reaches its proper level, we're
going to go ahead and start bleeding it.
[Music]
And so, like I said, I got the holes
running into a
bucket. And we'll go ahead and bleed
this front
[Music]
line. Here is the next setup. We're
going to bleed this side. And we got it
going into our bucket. Got the bucket
empty.
[Music]
Now we're going to bleed this side.
So, we got our setup.
[Music]
So, we're going to do the same thing to
drain all our delivery lines. And
basically you cut this over here and we
just do each one of them.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Heat
up here.
[Music]
This will be the third flush of the
auxiliary
line. No water in the line, but the
fluid was dark. So, going to drain them
until we can get clear fluid. So, let's
see if this one will do it. So, this is
the third flush.
[Music]
Heat
up here.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Once you got all your lines bled and
your hydraulic fluid filled back to the
right level, the next step is to come
around the
back and you're going to change your
hydraulic filter. So, we'll take that
out and change that filter. And then
next, you can see the gasket, which was
in pretty bad shape. But the gasket
goes beneath
here. And
then another one is here, sandwiched
between the filler cap.
So, you're going to put your gaskets
there. And then make sure you put
silicone, add silicone or RTV silicone
to it. And then on both spots, sandwich
it in. Put your screws back in. And then
to prevent it from happening again,
we're going to go down here and make
sure you have a gasket here, but you
want to put silicone around that and
then seal this back in. That way water
doesn't get in. And then for the top to
prevent water, you're going to take just
a regular plastic um container, you're
going to cut the top off of
it
and place it over the top. And then as
your cap go
down, as your cover go down, it'll hold
it. So that way it won't pop off while
you're working or anything and you won't
forget to put it back on.
So, that's what we'll get taken care of
next. So, this is one way to flush your
entire hydraulic system and to remove
all the contaminated oil out of the
system. It took me about 20 gallons to
flush the entire system. And that's
including the hydraulic lines. If you're
just using this process to change your
oil, the whole system takes about 6 and
12 gallons. So, if you're just changing
your oil, you won't use as much. So,
once we got all the contaminated oil
out, next thing we did is you have a
filter that's in here and you have
gaskets that's around there. You want to
make sure both of those are good. In our
case, all the gaskets were bad. So,
those are special order gaskets. So, in
case in that case, you may want to order
those in advance. Um, so what I did is
just made two and put those around and
then put silicone there. Make sure your
fil breather filter is good because
you'll get water in from here and that's
where the cover comes in and just make
this out of a simple container and cover
it up and that eliminate water going
through the breather. And then you want
to put silicone around the base of your
dipstick and that way you won't get
water in there. And then finally, you
want to make sure you change the
hydraulic filter. And once you've done
that, that should take care of all your
problems for as water getting in through
your reservoir. So, hope this video
helps. Don't forget to hit that like
button and subscribe and hit the
notification for more upcoming videos.
We'll talk to you later.
[Music]
Yeah. Yeah.